now we hear a lot about the metaverse
but my next guest heads a business that
claims to have been providing a bridge
between the physical and digital worlds
for the last 37 years oxford metrics
developed software supporting motion
measurement and helping infrastructure
owners such as highways authorities
manage their assets today the company
reported an 89 rise in pre-tax profits
to 4.8 million pounds for the full year
to the end of september the chief
executive of oxford metrics is nick
bolton and he joins me now nick very
good morning to you which are the parts
of the business where you've seen most
growth in demand lately
so
over the past 12 months um it's really
been in the area of virtual production
so we sell some technology that's used
uh for creating great shows like the
mandalorian you know the the disney ilm
star wars spin out and what we've seen
over the pandemic is actually
a retooling going on inside that
industry towards virtual production uh
techniques and what what that means is
that when originally it came about
because we couldn't get so many people
on set because of you know constraints
of population of vehicle density and so
forth and so they invented new ways then
to actually try to create these these
new shots with these led walls and
tracking cameras and that now has
actually become a trend that's
absolutely stuck and now there's a
fundamental retailing that's going on
inside those big tv and big big film
productions
and also
and certainly computer games so uh i
don't know if you're a video gamer but
the playstation 5 i'm sure you know has
been certainly been released and that
always strives and when those companies
come out with the
those new platforms they always drive an
upgrade cycle within our customer waste
and you know we've always had a very
strong presence in games so you know all
10 of the world's top 10 largest games
customers game companies are our
customers so as those constants come out
they do also help drive our business so
you know very much there's been we feel
over the past uh 12 months we you know
past two years with the pandemic we've
seen an acceleration of this coming of
the thing we call the augmented age
right which is this this partnership
where humans and machines are combined
to achieve more than anything can
achieve alone and the pandemics only
accelerated that interface between that
real world the virtual world that you
you know you mentioned in your
introduction you mentioned some of those
computer games companies as your
customers do you ever worry that they
might take some of the expertise that
you provide for them in-house and
develop it themselves
uh well they're very much focused on
creating those amazing games right so
their focus is in how do you create a an
engaging game uh experience that's all
about content that's about narrative and
so forth but they're still going to rely
on fundamental technology to be able to
capture the movements of the actors or
the of the athletes if they're working
on fifa soccer and so forth and that
really is where we come in so you know
we've been working in the game space uh
since 95 and so if if there was really
going to be a focus for them to sort of
come and try and implement the stuff
that we've already got i i think they
might have done it already by now rather
we see them as our very strong partners
and we're using our tools to then help
both guide what we need to develop in
the future but also help them realize
the amazing games that people get to
play these days now the other strand of
the business of course is infrastructure
management i think something like a
third of the uk's road network is
managed using your software does that
mean you're the people who are helping
implement smart motorways
uh so the software is is is an asset
management tool so it might be used to
manage certainly the roadways we all
drive on but also even the litter bins
and the emptying those litter bins uh
the lighting columns so you say you know
a third of the road network is our
customers are using it to manage about a
third of the uk's road network there's
actually half the uk streetlights are
being managed in our software uh as well
so it doesn't really matter regardless
of the asset type you know that can
still be managed in that in our in our
software and smart motorways is
certainly an element that is being uh
that is an area of attention for
managing uh assets as it would be you
know bournemouth high street uh as well
now you've talked a lot about what you
call smart sensing which are the great
untapped markets for for greater use of
sensors and monitoring
yeah i mean you're seeing it anyway you
know in all of our daily lives you can
buy an apple air tag which is a rather
nice encapsulation of smart sensing
that's one of those tags that you put in
your
on your key fob to make sure if you ever
lose your keys you can go to an app on
your phone and say where where are my
keys and it will identify you know where
it is so those sensors just as there are
sensors in my running watch that's
monitoring my heart rate or there are
sensors in our phone that world really
of of cheap available sensors coupled
with powerful analytical software that
can exist both on the device and in the
cloud is already present in in lots of
lives and i'm not saying that we're
going to dominate the world in all of
those areas but i think we have to look
to where
we we've got capability and heritage and
where our customer base is and that
broadly fits into four specific vertical
markets inside healthcare
inside engineering inside um
entertainment and inside research in all
those areas that's really where we've
been strong and so within those you know
they're all seeing those smart sensing
solutions being taken up so in games
it's about producing the gates but it's
also the way you experience uh those
those games um inside engineering it's
about
tools that enable an engineer to better
devise a new device or a new capability
so we've got a lot of the big tech
companies using using our tools i think
healthcare's perhaps the one that's
that's the most interesting um because
now you you we've you've got a way to
actually collect sensed information
about our health about our level of
activity and how idle are we when we sit
at our desk or what our range of motion
of our knee joint post um some surgery
that we've had because we had a bad
skiing accident and so forth effectively
instrumenting the quantified cell
instrumenting the self yeah in order to
be able to get data but actually you can
gather on a mass basis that researchers
can then look at and then actually make
better interventions with those people
because you've got that larger data set
i think that's probably for me the most
exciting area that i think can make a
real difference both to our business but
also actually the january to to our you
know our to our human condition to our
fellow people's lives that's a good
thing
now you mentioned data there obviously i
imagine you're collecting masses and
masses of data every day
who owns that data is it you or your
customers
it's really all of our customers so in
other words we we provide the tools by
which they gather uh data so if it's
someone like um nike or electronic arts
ea who are making a video game or trying
to understand an athlete they they buy
our system uh it gathers the data that's
stored locally then of course that's
then up to nike or ea or mit or nasa to
best manage that data on the healthcare
side clearly rightly so there are much
they're very clear constraints about
what you can do with patient information
and patient data and again that means
it's the hospital the research institute
who owns that
and then they manage all of those things
so although i would say our systems are
gathering a great deal of data
that doesn't come to us that was all
held locally by the uh by the individual
operator